what's going on reject nation we are
about to watch superman and lois
episode five today been loving the hell
out of this series is this going on
break
this is going hunt breakfast going on
break good that works because i am going
out of town
this sunday leaving for a week could be
caught up on superman and lowest at
least
but anything else big drops while i'm
gone you know why i'm not around for it
but guys it would help out the algorithm
if you could go ahead
hit that like button subscribe click
that notification bell if you haven't
done so
already do you gotta mention that
full-length reaction watch alongs where
you sync up with the time code
for superman and lewis are over at our
patreon page over there we cover
so many other tv shows a few movies
as well snyder cut whole bunch of jazz
thank you to everyone who has been
joining our patreon page just this past
week alone your support means a hell of
a lot
lastly got to thank perthrom jindal i
think i just butchered your name even
though i've gotten it right the past few
times
for editing these reaction highlights
for us you've been doing a great job i
know it's a lot to work around just to
get these public on youtube
hooray for cw thank you so much for
everything you do buddy let's get into
this
i've always loved smallville during the
fall
but what i loved most of all harvest
fest
i've been hearing about this from your
dad since we first started dating
bedtime stories help you sleep or what
think of it as smallville's version of
burning man minus the fires in b.o
and the lsd every year they have the
sugar bowl stand they make chocolate
bacon
good uh eliza is vegetarian so oh
oh hi eliza the harvest fest is special
okay it's gonna be super gentrified
hey sarah hey hey we always bump into
you
you're the only kid we bump into all the
time um you guys going tonight
yeah actually uh eliza's coming too what
about you
do you maybe want to go
together like from beginning to end
blazers
just freaks out on the spot
yeah no no yeah i would love to go great
for sure yeah i'll text you when eliza
is coming cool
okay there's a lot of bill with this
eliza girl coming
that speak of the devil oh she ain't
coming is she she's mephisto
oh she ain't coming what what are you
what are you talking about
eliza aka eliza can we can we please or
just talk about this
no she's breaking up with him over the
phone
all good welcome to smallville the place
where you get
dumped over the phone right oh
this guy is nothing but nice
he's getting this short end of the stick
in every corner he's gonna snap man
hey chrissy lois are you coming in soon
why what's going on she's bored kyle's
here
is she okay yeah she's okay actually
and so is her son oh
dang what happened no ma'am i was coming
through the tunnel and i was reading my
paycheck
ralph boner
[Laughter]
what about the uh phone messages you
left your mom well the doctors
said that with a hit to the head like
that it might take some time
for his memories return well huh yeah
might take some time before someone
replaces all of his memories with
something else
look miss lane we are so grateful for
your help but
i'm just so happy that he's back all
this other stuff it it
just doesn't matter
i have my son back you were almost
murdered by someone with superhuman
strength you're just gonna let that go
you want to write something right about
how my missing son has returned
that's a nice story her happy
son her enthusiastically positive son
has returned it appears we've
successfully located lois lane
captain luthor are you certain this is
the best question oh
damn whoever lost legos superman follows
no it's not love it's obsession lois is
the key
he's unhealthy healthily co-dependent
i love them together i'm joking
derek powell from new carthage
glad you're back
i'll go get the rest of the banks happy
ending
yeah it's gonna be great
oh god i gotta send a text uh
laura there's something wrong
is his head gonna blow i'm oh
now whoa
oh no
not the place man dude superpowers are
breaking out in smallville
so you can give people kryptonian powers
i guess
if you use them with kryptonian dna
that's how they're doing it
hybrids they're all a bunch of jordans
except jordan's good
i feel like it really pops yeah it's
definitely
assertive you know lana's gonna be there
i hope lana's played by the same actress
the totally different hairdo
see no alarms let's get out of here
easy now small build's a terrible place
sorry
thomas middle ditch no
[Music]
like we were never here
now we're an unloading crew you know
clark could have done that a lot faster
by himself
he'll let me unload those for you
that's cool seeing his little super boy
protecting smallville
wow just showed up clock style yeah
whoa
[Music]
awesome it must have been morgan edge
yeah he's dave's job fast freeze breath
[Laughter]
guys you got your favorite pizza i'm not
hungry liza
dumped in this morning delicate
no do you want to talk about it
what is there to talk about she knows
that she can do better than dating some
kid from some middle of nowhere town
i'm sure it's complicated for her too
sweetie our move here was really sudden
i'm just saying as a former teenage girl
myself you got to give it some time
and if she doesn't then it's her loss
well thanks for your cosmo girl opinion
but
oh
she was the main writer for the daily
planet yet
poor jonathan man my favorite character
getting duped
any idea what caused this was a morgan
edge
you know i don't know what's more
confusing have you seen this guy
anywhere near the center derek powell
i might have seen him come around back
hey that guy's starting to warm up to me
no that's a good exchange you do to get
his mom and get her to the gazette right
now
on it
so you're a reporter that's right so
what is it you have on morgan edge
nothing yet but i think i may have found
a way to get a look inside the mines
thanks if you managed to dig something
up give me a call
first you really said that to you
didn't even have the nerve you sent me a
text i mean
any chance i can see that text you and
derek wouldn't be sharing a phone plan
by any chance
that's the only way anyone can afford it
these days
dad i want to move back i lost all my
friends
it's all gonna work out you don't know
that brian kelso's older brother
has a place okay you just graduated from
met you maybe i could just
stay with them no you know what maybe
i'll just do it anyways then
because that's what jordan did with
football and you let him get away with
it
you can't be running around playing mass
vigilance but they were stealing
i understand that but we've got rules in
this family
those were dad's rules and he's not here
anymore
oh this is so interesting he taught your
father and i
both knew you were sent here for a
reason well i'm pretty sure that reason
wasn't to be martha kent's son
short john shauna jordan
place does look fun harbors festival boy
what's up boys okay text cubie2 we are
locked and loaded hell yeah
with what before the big game not cool
man i'm sure that's a good idea tonight
thanks for looking out mom uh this is
not you
he's gonna find out his only superman
power is hyper metabolism and he can't
get drunk
i don't know i started that fire
if he finds that it was me nothing is
going to happen oh my gosh
but if i can't control it we can fix
that yeah they're not real kryptonians
they're being made with those mining
shards
oh she'll solve the day huh
even they understand fair use rules and
music and this [ __ ] clark's like people
are gonna get copyright strikes
true superhero
that's a great transition good
transition show
what is this your father found it in a
pod when you arrive
i just know it belongs to you
step into my iron lung
i have predictions for what's gonna
happen to our reporter friend
she's gonna get a big scoop trust me
guys look it's everybody's favorite kid
brother it's mr
charming baby get this it's this guy's
first date
ever it's his first date oh no
oh wow you can't go one weekend without
partying like idiots
i'm kind of pathetic sarah hey look you
need to relax hey we're just kidding
don't talk to me like that
look uh he's you have no idea what real
problems are like
for people who don't come from a
picture-perfect family like you
we're just kidding i'm i'm sorry save it
have fun talk to you later
move look i'm i'm i'm sorry man i didn't
i didn't mean to ruin your night like
that it's all right
oh man get some water okay okay
these two i don't want either of them to
be evil
i don't think they're going to ah
they're gonna break our hearts somehow
okay so
sharon powell came into the office and i
like totally sleuthed my weight onto her
phone to get derek's location
so then i thought wwwd what would lois
lane do which is easy to sit deeper and
follow the lead only i never would have
thought
it would lead me to him making out with
leslie lar
she took him to this building where
there's this crazy brighter frankenstein
machine
clark is on it oh no
no did it work
cool what is this protect the asset
oh no
[Music]
projectile in motion sir speed and
flight pattern unique to kryptonian air
mobiles
here oh so you notice kal-el doesn't
know clark
oh what a great shot yeah
oh
no no
[Music]
oh damn stop it is
little town thrives off of this list
continue on this road and we'll
intersect in 23 seconds
take over auto driving oh god that he's
gonna get involved
no this is so bad
oh superman of steel vibes what does it
do to you
she resurrected me calhoun
like straight out of the man of steel
foot so
awesome ass music
okay it's gonna hit it's gonna freaking
hit superman isn't it damn it
i was gonna both of them
oh i gotta get the hell out of here
oh red kryptonite is that a guy here
with
or just some rocket blast that's a
pretty good guess i can help you
no you can't i'm already dead
oh that's what happened with tag
oh god i hope luther does not think he
killed him
jonathan i told you i know how you feel
and i do
when i was just a couple years older
than you i did leave home why
lots of reasons main one was that i
needed to become someone else
i'm freaking super one i thought was
more important than clark kent
and he never came back i still think
about that decision
jonathan you have your own path and it
might not feel like it right now but i
know it's gonna lead to great things all
i'm asking is that you give smallville
a little more time if after that things
still aren't working out
then we can discuss other options i'm
still trying to process what happened to
derrick powell
i can't believe you just killed himself
like that
this is nothing yeah
powers are erratic like tag harris
what's happening with tag whatever ed
that is fine that's that is a great
question i'm afraid tags gonna explode
i know it isn't much but uh every little
bit helps right just wish that we could
replace everything that was lost in the
fire
oh you're never going to believe this we
already have what
we're going to do yeah my man
wrote a check to replace everything and
then some very generous
where's kyle with his morgan edge
t-shirt
the harvest festival was your mom's
favorite time of the year
and we really feel her absence martha
kent
was everything this town aspires to be
everyone in smallville can remember her
sitting right here
guide her and though she is no longer
physically with us her spirit remains
and she will be right here
hell yeah
the train will be here any minute clark
and now we're at the point where our own
kids are talking about leaving home
it feels like they were just born it's
easy for you to say you didn't have to
go through 27 hours of labor
that's true damn wow
damn whole day in the making those were
27 episodes
that would have been a great first
season for superman at lowe's push
oh [ __ ] he just connected the dots
it is worth reminding you that this is
not the lowest lane from your world
everything about her is the same
[Music]
there are other variables that you have
not
that's crazy yes it was
i think i could really just use a friend
more than anything else god damn it the
zone
welcome to the zone man i get it jordan
you're my favorite character now
as long as we still get to spend some
time together oh keep up yeah
it's a television show so you'll get
with her yeah
yeah that's a friend zone's just the
first step
oh he said something really funny he did
oh who's going to snatch you up
that tag i think it might be tag
you're it oh what did you do to me
i'm in the x-men now
we'll get her an answer in a few weeks
yeah yeah yeah only a month away
the hell of a cliffhanger
all right what a fun fun episode fun
episode sup got a lot to get
done before heading out of town so we're
gonna keep this one a little bit short
but as i was expressing there at the end
those are some damn good cliffhangers
some damn good ones with tag
jordan in the friend zone with lex
luthor and
his unrequited love
that i did not see coming at all that
was a great reveal
because yeah as i was watching i was
thinking to myself like okay all right
he knows lois is always around so wait a
minute what's his story
yeah like on his planet if lois is
always around there's a superman but she
like also the only one on his planet who
was like covering superman before it
became evil
yeah but they didn't have a thing going
on and did superman then
develop some kind of fixation on her
because of that and like harass her in
that universe or like
that's why she won't be with me
luther you're my enemy and she's
publishing all these stories about me
i thought she loved me either way i
think that makes the conflict that much
more personal for the guy like he
already hates him
he already wants him gone and it'll show
up here and to see his doppelganger and
his perspective
his doppelganger lois
boinking it up with superman and having
children with the guy
i can only imagine how nutty
that is driving him and i love it i love
this scene that he had with lois too in
the coffee shop you do pick up on some
of that attraction i was i was just
thinking that guy was just charming i
didn't want to say anything
smooth because sometimes we might make
it a little too many jokes that
undercut the tension and people assume
that just because we made a joke that
means we're not into the show and that
we don't take any of it seriously
that by making said joke we have
completely
emotionally detached ourselves from
being connected to the series
so i didn't make a joke but he really
wanted to bang her in that scene
she's right there on the park bench oh
he was
willing man not in that scene in the
coffee scene
on the countertop geez pay attention
yes he had it's where his scene was with
her coffee
morgan morgan
i'm not gonna try to act like i'm all
superman knowledge
even though i am what i will talk about
is the filmmaking on this episode and
the writing
i love a good flashback
that is paralleling a journey in the
present
and i love whenever they tie it together
nicely i'm a big sucker for those kind
of things and sometimes i don't think
they're done well
and i thought they were done really well
here because
a this shined a light on something that
for some reason
and all 19 years i've been alive
i never thought about martha was a
single mom raising this kid for quite a
while
yeah depending on the lineage of
what story we're telling but like in
superman the movie he was in high school
when jonathan died i think it was that
in man of steel he was just played by
henry cavill
yeah i really developed high school i
don't remember
but yeah i mean he's still young what i
thought was neat about what they did
with young clark's story as much as it
did to help him identify
with his son johnny it also
goes to show how he can identify with
jordan as well
like his one story in this tale with
being raised by single mom
martha and then the regret of leaving
her behind so he could go find his own
identity as superman
cal l like finding all that his one
story
does let you in on he can i mean like
jordan was like an obvious one
super powers when you're young you're
misunderstood but even getting the side
of clark who was really hurt when he was
a kid and was angsty
it just felt very made it more human
actually yeah i thought this like
completely shed so many layers for the
guy like i loved it i
absolutely loved seeing that and seeing
single mom martha it was something like
we don't ever really see that do we
like that's why she has to raise this
kid who wants to be a hero as being a
vigilante in smallville
the show's done such a great job at
painting smallville in the worst life
the real killer of dreams and
aspirations i always thought smallmouth
was like this pleasant
identity yeah like that's how i think of
it
that's why when the two [ __ ] guys
were just flying around at the end when
he's like
they're like setting the barn on fire in
the crops i'm like this is
where their industry is yeah you're
killing this
stop this stop please
yeah that's a way in which you know they
certainly i guess obviously updated
things because now these are the kinds
of towns that wore
once idyllic and are now just run down
and depending on the bearish minimums to
get them by unless they have a morgan
edge type but those developments like
with lar and the whole like machine and
bringing people back from the dead
this is pretty sinister and like the
action sequences you were talking about
like when they're
flying through the corn and it's like
they're being pummeled with just
tons and tons and tons of chaff that's
got to be like a hefty cgi shot and it
looked really convincing and
it's like the amount of things that
they're pulling out of like the man of
steel playbook as well as like a classic
superman playbook and then as well as
like an elseworlds playbook
it's really fascinating to watch them
melt all together in a visual language
like this
you get some of those americana aspects
when you're early on in the episode and
clark is
like reminiscing about smallville and
that aura it's supposed to represent and
then later on seeing what it's become
i love the parenting parallels
throughout because you had such great
scenes between young clark
and ma kent and then you had these sort
of transcriptions of those into the
present with
clark and especially jonathan and you
know their interplay with lois you know
that it's because they
the both of them get to parent it's such
a cool thing about the show that the
action
is really impressive and it is
delivering on what you want from
superman but also there are so many
great little emotional flavors and
layers that they're playing with you
know
and jordan's in the friend zone
yeah i mean i think with all the
parenting stuff even with kyle
respect he didn't bring up morgan edge
one time not
one time they bring them up and that's
that's the main thing i know about the
guy
that's character developed it's scared
that's the writer is going we need even
more lives
let's let's give him a moment where he
remembers being a parent
the one thing i think they do such a
good job with that character is this is
such a small town community and you need
whoever plays him to really demonstrate
that
he loves the people in this town because
it's very easy to just make it kind of
funny
which it was for a while of like it's
all about jobs you know but it's not but
it's not really a greedy motivation that
he's got going on
in this episode they really go out of
their way to demonstrate this guy's got
a big heart
like he does he really cares that's the
whole reason he's always like morgan
edge money yeah like
it's because he really cares about these
people watching him have to deal
with trying to be a husband and a father
and a fighter of the fires otherwise
known as
fight fighter fight fight fire fire fire
fire fire fighting you're a fire man
fire man you know his best friend best
man at his wedding having to deal with
possibly him dying and the toll that it
takes on him i thought just
layered so much great humanity to him
like when he's talking with sarah
and he's doing the song uh the spanish
song
i think it was spanish it's sound in
spanish i don't speak spanish
it was probably armenian then it's yeah
kyle gives off
very strong armenian advice definitely
that's all i've been thinking about this
whole time is like when are they going
to reveal his true origin
yeah he's an armenian guy in
smallville usa but that's when he is
singing to sarah
this show has an attention to detail on
on psychology
on like an actual real psychological
sense they address
sarah and like we know that she sees
someone they make a clear
therapy talk therapy having to talk
about your emotional problems and all
that just what they do with their
characters here
like the the difficulties of being
vulnerable like he wasn't doing anything
bad by reminiscing there but it's
painful to try to
remember the good time it like hurts to
feel the good times and i love so i love
that reaction that sarah was giving
when she had her dad singing her like
that and yeah man
jordan being friend zoned by her dude
you took too long to act
you took way too long to act yeah after
that first
kiss you took way too long way too long
you could have done it man
and also jonathan man i gotta talk about
like jordan
it's it's interesting on the last couple
episodes it's
jonathan's been descending into a more
of a negative mindset while jordan's
been like
really chipper jordan's been a chipper
cat he's been hopping now he doesn't
even get that infuriated with his
brother
he's very understanding towards jonathan
all the pain jonathan's going through
getting cliche dumped on the phone like
that liz is coming
guys liz is coming liz is coming hey
everyone everyone guys
everyone unlock your doors this is going
to down
nothing back gonna happen that's why we
haven't got to hurry up we're waiting
for a big big big
big oh she's coming why's his car there
she is today's the day
the harvest festival it's the time but
his performance is so
good yeah there's a beautiful
performance yeah i got it i'm like dude
i'm on your side
the way that they have drawn that very
gradually of him like really trying to
stick with his ass
and john how they've drawn john
not john john's but john the finn kent
i have drawn john
no really beautiful because it's taken
several episodes for the facade to
really start to break and for you to
watch what coping mechanisms he's going
to reach for before he runs out of them
and so yeah i love the both tension but
also the heart
felt cords they're able to mix there
because like when
they're having the confrontation and
he's drunk clearly everyone's night's
been a little bit ruined i didn't know
what would happen i thought maybe there
could be an altercation between brothers
right here brothers fight
but you know to watch then yeah as
jordan that makes that decision to be
like
jonathan for just a second like what
would jonathan
say to me if i was in this position is
really how it
felt and it was cool to get that coming
back from jordan because so
much of their relationship with jonathan
looking out directly for jordan
yeah you know so yeah like again i'm
like
continuously impressed by what they try
to do with them dear to both of them i
don't think they're gonna anyone's gonna
be evil i take
i take that back i really don't think
either one of them's gonna turn evil
both i think both are gonna turn people
and so is superman and mark is gonna
turn evil
morgan and kyle hey dude but morgan edge
he paid for
the shelter yeah even though it's his
creation that destroyed the shelter
so you know he was like i feel bad i
guess i better reimburse everybody
it's gonna look suspicious there's a lot
of moving
puzzle pieces now there's i'm i'm
starting to wonder how it's all gonna
coalesce by the end because for to wait
a few weeks there's a lot of
threads here you know and this show's
only six episodes
[Laughter]
so they're really building up to that
for that yeah it's gonna be a four-hour
finale
well you got the awesome she could just
be comic relief but i love how they
paint her as way more than that the one
who's
at the uh uh smallville planet or who
was there
yeah yeah tessa tessie or something yeah
she's brilliant in the show i think
she's brilliant oh and um having
her uncover this mystery alongside lois
lane
who continues to kill in her acting
abilities having all
that and then you have the luther and
then you got kryptonians then you got
morgan edge
and then you got tag and what's
there she's happening elizabeth back
where's eliza well and who else are they
gonna run through the kryptonia uh the
kryptonite the whole town
oh a small building yeah yeah extreme
you got it all to come true
oh yeah yeah it's new kryptonian right
that would be dope you know seymour
martha was great here too and how like
the town honors that
i think is beautiful i like how when
clark running away was
he actually was saying goodbye he didn't
just leave yeah yeah
he's like i'm going yeah he could
like i thought it was great to capture
in that really human way instead of just
i'm packing up i'm leaving
bye like an angry thing or a hurt thing
or not telling his mom it was like no
she's saying goodbye to him on the bus
like that was
yeah just don't expect that and then to
be honored on the bench and to
be like your mom was always here and
it's like maybe she was always there
because of that moment
oh hey that's a very astute observation
i know i feel more than sarcasm so
i was saying that like yeah that's
probably why she always went back there
what was it and then so it's like to
have this moment honoring her
and then of how that makes clark feel
like guilty because that's the last time
he saw her
not the last time sorry but that was the
beginning of the years he
wasn't with him yeah left for a while
after that and missed definitely some
moments of life with her yeah i was
powerful yeah
it's a really beautiful episode and i
don't know if people talk about it
likewise well
i mean that's the thing is i feel like
the more humanity they give to clark the
brighter that shines and especially
when they choose those moments where he
doesn't have to do it the human way
they mean so much more because then
they're really about the time taken and
the relationship honored
it's funny to see how many like truly
poignant not just like oh you know
little here's a little character scene
that's sweet like truly poignant scenes
that you can then extrapolate you know
life out of i think is really
well attuned here all right guys well
superman and lois
what do you think of the show so far do
you think luther
will be able to engage in a three
part encounter
orgy with kyle
and lana let me know definitely
see so that's how you do comedy you're
like oh he's gonna say
lois and clark get to the joke but no
i used a different couple
jordan and sorry so
subscribe click that bell thank you
pratham for editing only the review and
not the reaction highlights
thanks for making us sound good thanks
buddy
and hey before i go out of town i think
it's important
to shout out some people who have been
good people
at our ten dollar tier patreon page
chase morgan stephen mendoza
sandrine little angel
rogue cree sam castle
sj94 spencer
just martin kayla
rosie the baby darth vader 66
ruby dynamite philip j smith
jr jen smith brihana
david sun melanie
brittney bayerly
natalie doran irwin roachier marcus
vorderman
chase gardner tiana h
and ava drasdakova thank you john for
recruiting all these people to our
patreon page with your charm and good
looks and six pack abs i know that's why
you guys are here
appreciate your support big time
hopefully
you guys have been enjoying being part
of the patreon page
if not submit all your feedback to
um tyrone the magnus yahoo.com
he'll help you out he feels all our
complaints thank you guys again
much love
[Music]